Alright, let's look at one last trait for this
lesson. Sickle Cell Anemia. People with Sickle Cell Anemia have
a haemoglobin protein that changes the shape of red
blood cells and reduces the flow of oxygen in the
body. The lack of oxygen delivery caused by the
anemia can be quite painful. Now in the United States,
about one in 5,000 people have Sickle Cell Anemia. But
in some regions of Subsaharan Africa, there are actually 1
in 50 people. Let's bring back our fictional
family with an African American background, a pedigree of
Bobby and his family. It shows here that Bobby
has an affected cousin. And an affected great grandparent
on his father's side. Now just like the other
traits, before we get involved into the genetic basis,
I want you to tell me a little bit
more about the inheritance patterns that you see here.
I want you to tell me if the
inheritance pattern most resembles that of an autosomal, sex-linked,
or maternal trait. And also try to decide if
the trade appears to be more dominant or recessive.